ilils ont entraîné des militairs
ukukrainiens dans leur propre
papays. L'invasion russe à la fn
féfévrier a forcé l'interruption
dede la mission canadienne.
ANANITA ANAND,
miministre de la Défense natione
- - Aujourd'hui, j'annonce que
nonous tenons notre promesse de
rereprendre l'opération UNIFIER.
- - Dans les prochaines semaine,
lala formation par des soldats
cacanadiens reprendra
popour quatre mois, mais
cecette fois-ci, au Royaume-Uni,
unun pays qui entraîne déjà
dedes militaires ukrainiens.
- - Cet échange de connaissances
enentre nos deux forces militais
a a nettement amélioré les choss
susur le terrain.
- - Mais alors que le gouvernemt
TrTrudeau réitère son soutien
inindéfectible envers s l'Ukrai,
sasa loyauté envers le pays
esest remise en doute.
C Comme le gouvernement Zelens,
lele Congrès des Ukrainiens-
CaCanadiens ne comprend toujours
papas pourquoi le Canada a
cocontourné ses propres sanctio,
etet renvoyé en Allemagne
unune turbine, qui devait
pepermettre e au pays de recevor
dudu gaz naturel russe.
" "Est-ce que l'Ukraine est
enencore un allié du Canada",
dedemandent les Conservateurs?
D'D'autant que le renvoi
dede la turbine n'a rien changé
popour l'instant.
L Le gazoduc Nord Stream 1 qui
rerelie la Russie à l'Allemagne
nene fonctionne toujours pas
àà pleine capacité.
" "Pourquoi est-ce
ququ'on continuerait de
sese plier au chantage de Moscou
enen acheminant d'autres
tuturbines", demande le NPD?
L Le ministre Wilkinson rappele
quque le Canada a des obligatios
enenvers ses alliés européens,
enencore très dépendants
dudu gaz russe.
D Des contraintes bien réelles
popour les Européens, qui forcet
lele Canada à passer outre ses
enengagements, quitte à décevoir
leles Ukrainiens. C'est donc
unun nouveau jeu d'équilibriste
popour le gouvernement Trudeau
ququi l'expose, encore une fois,
àà la critique.
I Ici Laurence Martin,
R Radio-Canada, Ottaw